je vais en février le président
ukrainien volodimir delince qui a lancé
un appel aux volontaires étrangers pour
se battre au sens d'une légion
internationale contre les russes vingt
mille combattants étrangers auraient
déjà répondu à l'appel dont des français
n'est pas la première fois que des
français volontaires décide de prendre
les armes pour défendre un autre pays
dans les années 30 en pleine guerre
d'espagne des milliers d'entre eux sont
partis combattre un général félon dans
mes franco avait pris des armes contre
la république espagnole avec l'abe
d'hitler et de mussolini de toute
l'europe des démocrates décidé de
rejoindre les brigades internationales
créées pour défendre la république de
grands nous rejoignent les brigades
internationales comme la philosophe
simone weil et l'écrivain andré malraux
il est possible que toute révolution
commence par son illusion lyrique chez
krt à dire par la puissance de sa
fraternité la fraternité c'est ce qui a
poussé certains français à prendre les
armes contre le frontisme nous sentions
que si on était pas qu contre eux ça
viendrait enfance la suite des
événements a bien un vrai confirmé que
c'était nous qui avions raison plus
proche de nous dans les années 90 des
français se sont engagés en croatie
contre les serbes exemple cette
quinzaine de combattants français dont
certains sont proches de groupuscules
d'extrême droite pour moi le croate
saint pée européen
ce sont des européens
d'abord leur indépendance
pour se démarquer par rapport
auxerre que sont des communistes des
français qui combattent par conviction
mais qui parfois se confrontent avec des
mercenaires depuis 2003 une loi condamne
à 5 ans de prison et 75000 euros
d'amendé toutes activités de mercenariat
mais cette loi ne freine pas les
volontaires au combat en 2014 des
français rejoignant ainsi les
combattants russes en ukraine ici ces
deux europe qui se battent l'europe de
l'union européenne de l'ultralibéralisme
celle de l'impérialisme américain de la
déliquescence des valeurs morales du
mariage gay de la suite de la famille de
l'athéisme et l'europe de la russie de
la de la famille traditionnelle des
valeurs saines vous êtes payés ah non on
n'est pas payé en sus on était payé on
aurait été content
et en 2000 ted sur un autre terrain de
guerre des français rejoignent les
kurdes pour combattre l'état islamique à
46 ans franck est un ancien militaire au
chômage qui a notamment servi dans la
gendarmerie pourquoi vous combattez des
bas parce que des chaussées l'ennemi du
monde mais vous êtes facture non je ne
suis pas kurdes je suis français je suis
français je suis un citoyen du monde et
j'ai envie d'aider le monde une envie
d'aider le monde avec à la clé le risque
d'être blessé
tu es ou poursuivies à leur retour en
france
[Musique]